.
WE ARE ALMOST AT THE END OF THE
WEEKEND IF YOU'RE LIKE ME, YOU
ARE PROBABLY REALLY ATTRACTIVE.
SO SOMETIMES WHEN A CRIME IS
COMMITTED WE FOCUS ON THE MAIN
PURPOSE, BUT NOT THE ACCESSORIE
EXCEPT THAT IN THE WORLD OF
COVERUPS IN POLITICS IT'S THE
ACCESSORIES YOU SEAL THE DEAL.
I SPEAK OF THE 51 SO-CALLED
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIVES WHO
SIGNED A WIDELY PLOTTED DOCUMEN
NAMING HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP
COULD BE RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
THE KEY WORD BEING COULD BE AND
I COULD BE A BOTTLE OF KETCHUP.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU CAN
TURN ME UPSIDE DOWN AND SPANK M
BOTTOM.
WHILE YOU CAN, BUT YOU HAVE TO
ASK ME FIRST.
EVERY TALKING HEAD HE WANTED
TRUMP GONE LIKE IT WAS THE TEN
COMMANDMENTS.
OR THEY HAIR.
BUT NOW REPUBLICANS ARE SAYING
THEY SHOULD EXPECT SUBPOENAS
NEXT YEAR IF THEY DON'T TELL US
HOW THEY REACH THEIR WRONG
COMPLETION COMPLETION AND UNISO
WITHOUT EVERY EVIDENCE IN THE
MISS CLEO DEEP INTO A BOTTLE OF
SCOTCH.
AFTER ALL IT HELPED THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN KILLED PRE-ELECTION
COVERAGE LINKING JOE TO HAVE.
IT'S INCREDIBLE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, THE MEDIA OUR
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE SHADOWED
GOVERNMENT, ONE THAT LIKE OUR
ACTUAL GOVERNMENT RUTHLESSLY
GETS THINGS DONE.
THE DECIDE HOW TO AMPLIFY THE
LIE AND ULTIMATELY THEY GOT THE
AMERICANS TO GO THE WAY THEY
WANTED THEM TO VOTE GREAT I HOP
THEY SAID CNN AND MSNBC THANK
YOU, AND NOW, A YEAR AND A HALF
AFTER KILLING A STORY THEY ARE
VERIFYING THE DATA FOR IN
LOBBYING CRIMES BUT WHY NOW,
BECAUSE IT SERVES A PURPOSE.
TELL US, WISE MAN.
>> THEY SUPPRESSED IT.
>> HIM INCOME AND NOW THEY ARE
RELEASING IT.
>> HIM OUT.
HOW DOES THAT GUY KEEP GETTING
YOUNGER?
THREE WORDS CARROT SMOOTHIE.
HE MAKES A GOOD POINT.
THEY MANIPULATED THE BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY LIKE A SPIGOT, THE
NEEDED JOE TO GET ELECTED, SO
THEY TURNED IT OFF, AND NOW THA
HE'S BECOME AN ALBATROSS AROUND
THE PARTIES NOT YOUR MOTHER
TURNING IT.
THE HUNTER BIDEN BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIPS HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH WHO SHOULD BE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> IT'S NOT INTERESTING.
WE THINK ABOUT THE TIME IN THE
MEXICAN PERSON, OF COURSE HE'S
NOT INTO A.
WHY COVER A STORY THAT MAKES YO
LOOK SO BAD.
WHEN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA LOOK
STUPID.
THEY CAN CALL IT CNN PLUS.
>> SPEAKING OF COMING HERE IS A
GREAT MOMENT FROM A SYMPOSIUM O
DISINFORMATION WHEN A BRIGHT KI
ASK BRIAN STELTER EXACTLY WHAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN ASKING.
>> OF ALL SPOKEN EXTENSIVELY
ABOUT FOX NEWS BEING A PURVEYOR
OF DISINFORMATION, BUT CNN IS
RIGHT UP THERE WITH THEM, THEY
PUSH THE RUSSIAN COLLISION HOAX
THEY PUSH THE FACE MIRRORED
JUSTICE CAVANAGH AS A AND THEY
ALSO AS A WHITE SUPREMACIST AND
YES, THEY DISMISSED THE HUNTER
LAPTOP AS PURE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION WITH CORPORATE
JOURNALIST BECOMING LITTLE MORE
THAN APOLOGISTS AND CHEERLEADER
FOR THE REGIME, AT THIS TIME TO
FINALLY BE CLEAR THAT THE CANON
OF JOURNALISTIC ETHICS IS DEAD
OR NO LONGER OPERATIVE ALL THE
MISTAKES OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDI
IN CNN IN PARTICULAR SEEMED TO
MAGICALLY ALL GO IN ONE
DIRECTION.
ARE WE EXPECTED TO BELIEVE THIS
IS ALL JUST SOME SORT OF RANDOM
COINCIDENCE OR IS THERE
SOMETHING ELSE BEHIND IT?
>> IT'S TIME FOR LUNCH.
>> IT'S ALWAYS LUNCH WITH THAT
GUY.
THE WEIRD THING IS IT WAS ONLY
EIGHT IN THE MORNING.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T THINK THESE AR
NEEDED THIS.
AND WHAT HAPPENS LATER WHEN YOU
GET CAUGHT.
ABOUT THE REST OF THE DEMOCRATI
RAT PACK.
THEY CLAIMED THE NEAR FIRST.
THAT INCLUDES ALL THE BIG NAMES
LIKE MICHAEL HAYDEN AND OF
COURSE THE IRONICALLY NAMED
JASON CLAPPER KLAPPER HE'S NEVE
DONE ANYTHING WORTHY OF APPLAUS
FOR THEY SAW NO REAL EVIDENCE
THAT THEY SAID THE RUSSIANS DID
IT.
THE TECHNICAL TERM FOR THAT IS
MAKING LEAP UP.
THEY'VE PUBLISHED A SHOW THAT
THEY TOOK PART IN BUSINESS
DEALINGS BRIDGE SHOWING THAT TH
BIG GUY WAS MORE ALERT AND HIS
SHENANIGANS THAT HE IS AT HIS
OWN PRESS CONFERENCES.
SAYING HE DIDN'T IS LIKE SAYING
MICHAEL LINDELL HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH MY PILLOW.
I WONDER WHAT THE NEW YORK TIME
OR THE WASHINGTON POST WILL
DECIDE THAT THIS IS FINALLY REA
WHERE THEY WAIT 18 MONTHS?
I WONDER WHAT JOE THINKS.
>> LOOK.
COME ON THEN.
HERE IS THE DEAL.
I MEAN, YEARS AND NEEDS HELP,
YOU HELP HIM OUT, THAT'S WHAT I
DO THINGS RIGHT IF YOU LIKE
FACEBOOK, EATS WORK ON YOUR
FASTBALL, YOU THROW A FEW AROUND
.
IF HE LIKES MAKING MONEY FOR
CORPORATE REGIMES IN EASTERN
EUROPE, YOU THROW HIM A BONE.
IT'S WHAT I DO.
IN THE BIG GUY.
HERE'S THE DEAL, TO BE HONEST,
THOUGHT IF YOU MADE A COUPLE OF
SUITCASES FULL OF CASH, MAYBE H
WOULD LOSE THE BAD HABITS, BUT
WE KNOW HOW THAT TURNED OUT,
RIGHT?
WHILE.
SO THE COVER-UP WAS MEANT TO
SWAY AN ELECTION BY MISLEADING
THE AMERICAN VOTERS.
WORSE, RELYING ON EVIDENCE, BUT
EXCLUDING THEIR EXTREME RESUMES
IN NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERIENCE
AND NOW THEY MAY BE SUBJECT TO
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION.
IT'S IRONIC THE INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS DID NOT SEE THIS
COMING.
WHERE IS THE INTELLIGENCE IN
THAT.
IT'S LIKE A PALM READER GETTING
HIT BY A BUS.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST,
HE SERVES AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
ONE MORE TIME HE GETS A GREEN
LIZARD AT DAIRY QUEEN, FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE UNITED
STATES, AND AUTHOR OF THE GREAT
NEW BOOK ONE THING AFTER ANOTHER
, BILL BARBIER HAD AND IF
YOU THINK HIS JACKET IS CHEESY,
WAIT UNTIL YOU HEAR HIS JOKES.
BOX ACROSS AMERICA HOST JIMMY
BAILOUT.
>> SHE IS THE REASON HOUSES IN
DETROIT FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KA
TIMPF.
FINALLY, ELEPHANTS DON'T WANT T
TALK ABOUT THE TYRUS IN THE ROOM
.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK TYRUS.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> YOU MIGHT WAKE UP ON
"OUTNUMBERED."
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THE MEDIA
COVERAGE FREIGHT I KNOW YOU
CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT.
>> THIS IS SIMPLY A GROSS
EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING THAT'S ON
DAILY BASIS FOR ME.
WE TALK ABOUT THE HANDWRINGING
THAT WAS DONE OVER IN THE
ELECTION, THIS KIND OF THING HA
A FAR GREATER IMPACT BRICKEY I
THINK THE IMPACT TO, AT LEAST
FOR SOMEBODY LIKE ME AND PEOPLE
OF OTHER ATTRACTIVE PEOPLE I
CAN'T BELIEVE ANYTHING ANYMORE.
I'M EVEN DOUBTING PICTURES.
MAY BE IT'S HEALTHY WE'VE ALL
BECOME CYNICAL, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> PEOPLE HAVE TO HAVE FAITH AN
NOT ONLY ELECTIONS, BUT ALSO
FEEL THAT WE ARE ALL OPERATING
FROM SOME COMMON SET OF FACTS.
TO MAKE DECISIONS.
AND THEN WE FIND OUT WHERE NOT,
MUCH LIKE HER JACKET.
IT LOOKS LIKE A BEEHIVE EXCLUDED
.
>> THAT'S A FUNNY STORY NOBODY
KNOWS.
I SAW YOU OUT WITH YOUR WIFE,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO INTERRUPT
YOU BECAUSE SHE WAS ASKING THE
WAITER FOR A BOOSTER SEAT AND I
WAS CONTENTIOUS, I DIDN'T WANT
TO SCREW IT UP RIGHT, BUT YOU
TALK ABOUT THIS, I LOVE THIS.
IT'S SO GOOD.
FIRST OF ALL --
DO YOU KNOW THAT EVERYONE IN TH
ATLANTIC IS LECTURING ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF --
THEY HAVEN'T MUCH ABOUT THE OF
MARIJUANA YET.
>> THEY CALL THEMSELVES THE
ATLANTIC.
IF YOU REMEMBER WHO RAN THE
ANONYMOUS SOURCE REPORT ON
VETERANS WITH 23 PEOPLE AND
RECORD DENYING IT.
THEY WERE REALLY TO RUN THE
STORY.
THEY WILL COVER THE STORY WITH
MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE, NOT TO
MENTION JOB TO JOHN RADCLIFFE
SAYING IT AT THE ELECTION.
AND HIS BUSINESS PARTNERS SAYIN
IT WAS A FAKE.
EVERYBODY WATCHING AT HOME,
THERE IS NO WORLD FOR HUNTER
BIDEN GET THIS MONEY WITHOUT IS
BAD.
>> Shannon: --
WITHOUT IS DEAD BEING VICE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S GOING TO BOOST PROFITS.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THEM DOWN?
STOP IT.
YOU CAN'T BE A KARDASHIAN
ANYMORE.
TOO MANY SELFIES.
YOU GO --
YOU KNOW, TIRES, JOE SAID
SOMETHING, HE SAID THAT IS NOT
SCINTILLA OF EVIDENCE.
AND HE IS RIGHT.
IT WAS AN AVALANCHE.
SCINTILLA IS LIKE A SHRED OF
EVIDENCE.
>> BASE COACH.
HOW DARE YOU THERE GROW UP.
HE HAS A HIGH CHAIR.
SOMEBODY DID THAT.
THESE ARE AMERICAN MARTYRS.
THEY COULDN'T HAVE WHAT HAPPENE
IN THE PREVIOUS ELECTION WHERE
HILLARY'S LAUNDRY CAME OUT OF
THE FINISH LINE AND THEN IT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO THEY ALL FELL ON THEIR SWORD
TO SAVE THE COUNTRY FROM
PROBLEMS, LIKE EVERYTHING
FALLING TO --
BUT THEY KEPT HIM OUT.
AND WE ARE ALL KNEE-DEEP IN IT
NOW.
SO JOB WELL DONE.
>> THAT IS SUCH A GREAT POINT.
THEY SAW THIS AS A GROWTH THAT
NEVER MIND THE MORALITY.
BUT WE WILL WORRY ABOUT THAT
LATER.
>> YOU JUST GOT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RED DRAGON DOESN'T GET
IN THERE.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE BETTER
.
IS GOING TO BE NO INFLATION, NO
HORRIBLE ECONOMICS OF NO CRIME
AND NO WARS.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING THEY
ACCUSE HIM OF WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN IF HE WAS IN HAPPENED
WHEN THEY GOT IN.
>> Greg: AND WHEN HE GOT OUT.
>> QUICK THROW WHATEVER.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, KAT, I HAD
A ROUGH DAY TODAY.
I DRINK SOME BAD WINE LAST NIGHT
.
>> WE KNOW.
THANKS FOR THE TEXTS.
>> Greg: ANYWAY, KAT, JAMES
BIDEN, JAMES BIDEN GOT LIKE
$17 MILLION WIRE FROM CHINA AND
THEN THERE WAS LIKE A 150 OTHER
WEIRD WIRES GOING ON AND THEN
APPELBAUM THINK THIS IS A REALL
BORING STORY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY IT.
I THOUGHT I HAD HEARD THE WORST
TAKES ON THIS ALREADY BUT TO
CALL THIS NOT INTERESTING, OKAY
SMOKING CRACK WITH ESCORTS,
STRIPPER BABY MAMAS.
WE AS A COUNTRY FIND THAT
INTERESTING ARE WE NOT BE ON
SEASON 31 OF MORE EAT.
I DON'T THINK THAT IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF ANY AT THIS.
IF YOU WANT STRIPPERS, THAT IS
BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR DOCTORS.
BUT IT IS THE CORRUPTION PART
THAT POTENTIAL CORRUPTION
LOOKING AT THIS, THAT IS THE
PART THAT I THINK REALLY MATTER
BUT DON'T SAY IT'S NOT
INTERESTING WHEN THERE IS CRACK
AND ESCORTS AND STRIPPER BABY
MAMAS.
>> Greg: AND IT'S INTERESTING.
I GOT EVERYTHING I WANTED.
>> ALL HE NEEDED WAS THE GUITAR.
HE WOULD HAVE AND DRUGS AND ROC
'N ROLL.
REALLY INTERESTING.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE ALL THREE.
>> THESE ARE THE NICKNAMES, THE
BIG GUY.
WE GOT THE BIG GUY.
>> HE'S UNDER A BRIDGE AND NEW
JERSEY.
>> Greg: THAT'S ENOUGH.
NE